[Music]
welcome back to CBS this morning
Starbucks is joining a growing list of
companies that plan to suspend some of
their social media advertising because
of online hate speech Facebook and its
co-founder and CEO Mark Zuckerberg is
one of the main targets of the company's
efforts civil rights organizations have
called for an ad boycott of Facebook
saying it does not do enough to stop
racist and violent content
Jericka Duncan looks at what Starbucks
and the other businesses are hoping to
accomplish with a commanding 40% share
of the American coffee shop market and
the deep pockets of flood Facebook
Instagram and Twitter with millions in
promotion Starbucks says it's forcefully
hitting the pause button on paid
advertising across its social media
platforms in a statement Starbucks
announced its intention to stand against
online hate speech saying in part both
business leaders and policy makers need
to come together to effect real change
the boycott follows similar pledges from
other Fortune 500 brands like coca-cola
and Unilever Starbucks did not mention
to stop hate for-profit campaign which
calls on big brands to pull ad spending
from Facebook it is time once and for
all
for Mark Zuckerberg and for Facebook to
stand and to take a stand against hate
Jonathan Greenblatt is the CEO a
national director of the anti-defamation
league one of the organizations behind
stop hate for profit what are you hoping
this campaign will actually achieve it's
long overdue for Facebook to put a real
civil-rights infrastructure together at
the highest levels of the corporation to
make sure these issues get the attention
that they need if we determine the
content may lead to violence or deprive
people of their right to vote we're
going to take that content down no
matter who says it Facebook announced
new guidelines this past Friday after
the company's share price tumbled more
than 8% slashing 56 billion dollars from
its value the biggest brands in the
world are saying
they are no longer willing to subsidize
stereotypes they want to stop hate for
profit in a statement to CBS News
Facebook says it invests billions of
dollars every year to improve its
policies and that it will continue to
work with experts to stomp out that hate
speech that's their Starbucks Starbucks
says in social media pods
does not include YouTube as they see
YouTube as a video platform that does
not engage with its customers in the
same way that Facebook does Anthony
thanks tarika so much nasty stuff on
social media and pressure now from
businesses too to fix it